what is most revolting to a man is a
woman who has slept with many men and
rather than repenting of those ways
instead has this attitude about it why
do you think men care about a woman's
body count do you
actually care about that men in general
if a man is asking me a body count he
can get if a man is ever asking you
about your body count you're talking to
the rod man and he can get like that's
so stupid if she has a habit of jumping
in the bed with every other guy she
meets then he's going to worry that this
habit of following her carnal desires
above all will increase the likelihood
that she'll continue in that behavior
even after making a commitment to him a
man wants to be able to say about his
woman that is it is unimaginable that
she would jump into bed with some random
guy she meets at the gym or whatever but
even if she was single she wouldn't do
that that's what a man wants to be able
to say but if the man knows that if she
was single she would do that then the
man will worry justifiably so that she
will do that even when she's not single